this video is kindly sponsored by keeps
more on them later on hey 42 here
sometime in the late 1880s the lifeless
body of a young woman was fished out of
the river scent that flows through paris
the girl looked to be about 16 years of
age and since there wasn't a mark on her
it was assumed she died by drowning
perhaps having committed suicide
attempts were made to identify the young
woman in the days after her body was
recovered from the water
but nobody knew who she was and no
friends or family ever came forward to
claim her to this day her true identity
remains an intriguing mystery but
despite the twin handicaps of being both
dead and of unknown entity
this woman went on to infiltrate
thousands of homes across europe and
inspire some of the greatest artists in
history from pablo picasso to michael
jackson she's even earned the unofficial
title of being the most kissed person of
all time
an unusual accolade that's helped her
save millions of lives around the world
as confusing and unlikely as all of that
may sound believe me it's completely
true
stick around and all will soon become
clear
because this is the utterly remarkable
and largely forgotten story
of the unknown woman of the set
a girl who died in obscurity in paris
130 years ago but who lives on today in
the most unexpected
and incredible way
now i want to take a moment to talk
about hair loss because i've had people
close to me start to lose their hair as
early as their 20s and it's always been
an upsetting experience
if you're in the same boat then you're
not alone did you know two out of three
guys will experience some form of male
pattern baldness by the time they're 35
but the best thing you can do to prevent
hair loss is take the initiative now and
do something about it whilst you've
still got hair left i like keeps because
it makes treatment super easy by
delivering your hair loss medication
every three months so you could say
goodbye to awkward doctor visits and
waiting in pharmacy checkout lines
there's a good reason that keeps has
more five-star reviews than any of its
competitors and hundreds of thousands of
men trusts them for their hair loss
prevention medication
so if you're like me you're probably not
ready to lose your hair just yet but
prevention is key the faster you act the
faster you'll see results and the sooner
you start using keeps the more hair
you'll save
if you're noticing that you're losing
your hair do something about it for a
limited time go to keeps.com
or click the link in the description
below to receive 50
off your first order
like all good stories this one starts in
a morgue
the paris morgue to be precise a
building which in the late 19th century
could be found right in the heart of the
french capital just a stone's throw away
from notre dame cathedral
this prominent location was no
coincidence it had been carefully
selected by city officials to ensure the
morgue attracted as many visitors as
possible
that might seem like an odd goal for a
morgue you'd think keeping the numbers
down would be preferable in a place for
the dead
but this wasn't your average funeral
parlor
in fact at the time the paris morgue was
one of the city's most popular tourist
attractions people from all over the
city and far beyond flocked to its
public viewing gallery to get a good
look at the day's fresh corpses which
were laid out like exhibits in a museum
if the morgue staff were feeling
particularly creative they'd sometimes
dress the dead in fancy clothes and
place them in life-like positions adding
to the surreal spectacle
as weird as all of that may sound there
was actually a fairly sensible
explanation for this apparently
macarthur behavior well not the dressing
got part i've no idea what all of that
was about
but the rest of it at least making the
mug accessible to the public spared
officials the time-consuming job of
tracking down the relatives of the
city's growing number of unidentified
dead if a loved one went missing instead
of sitting at home worrying you could
simply pop your head in at the morgue
and make sure they weren't dead
but whilst the reasoning was sound
sort of
opening the paris morgue up to joe
public had some unexpected consequences
driven by an irrefutable fact of human
nature one that can be proved easily
enough with a spare five minutes and a
reliable internet connection
we humans are a bit
which is why as well as concerned
relatives searching for missing loved
ones
the paris morgue was visited by
basically everybody it became so popular
that it even began appearing in the
city's guidebooks and tourist pamphlets
alongside world famous museums and
galleries
interest in the morgue was further
fueled by grisly stories in the
newspapers which presented parisians
with a new and unique form of
entertainment they could read about a
brutal murder in the paper in the
morning then head to the morgue to get a
good look at the mutilated body of the
victim in the afternoon by all accounts
a lovely way to spend a sunday the most
popular attractions well rotting corpses
are said to have brought in as many as
40 000 spectators a day and spawned
extensive side industries for both
vendors and pickpockets
the particular corpse i want to tell you
about today the so-called unknown woman
of the sen
was not so far as we know one of the
morgue's high-profile attractions
or at least no official record survive
of her time there but that doesn't mean
she didn't get her first share of
attention
when the moog's bodies weren't being
dressed up in funny clothes for no
reason whatsoever they were usually laid
out pretty much naked which is why in
those more sexually repressed times a
young woman at the morgue was always a
source of keen interest
whilst there were no doubt plenty of
admiring glances from members of the
public it was one of the morgue's own
members of staff who really took a shine
to this dead woman
so much so that when no relatives came
forward to claim her body this man
decided to take the young girl home with
him instead
not her rotting corpse obviously
that would be mental
no he decided to take a plaster cast of
the unknown woman's face so that he
could admire it from the privacy of his
own home for the rest of his days
the creepy bastard
in truth there might not have been
anything especially sinister about the
man's actions
unsettling though they may sound it was
the morgue's custom that unclaimed
bodies be taken away after three days
and buried in unmarked graves they were
usually starting to fall apart by that
stage anyway
the death mask may simply have been a
way of recording the girl's features
just in case anyone came looking for her
either way the cast was made a near
perfect reproduction of the dead girl's
face
exactly how that cast came to be
reproduced in greater quantities isn't
clear but in time the unknown woman of
the sen's face began to appear on the
walls and mantelpieces of houses first
across paris and then far beyond
for whatever reason something about that
serene almost blissful face
just got under people's skin
especially those with creative
tendencies a generation of european
writers took it turns to invent their
own backstory for this nameless girl
some painted her as an orphan others as
a witch or the victim of a crime
vladimir nabokov author of the
enormously controversial novel lolita is
said to have owned and treasured a copy
of the death mask and the great pablo
picasso hung one on the wall of his
studio it was another philosopher and
nobel prize winning golfer albert camus
another proud owner of the death mask
who noticed its resemblance to another
well-known parisian resident
the mona lisa
and you have to admit there is something
to that comparison those enigmatic half
smiles are almost eerily similar
quite the coincidence considering the
unknown woman of the sen was pulled from
the river less than 200 meters away from
where da vinci's masterpiece hangs in
the louvre to this day
perhaps unsurprisingly considering she
seemed to have cast a spell on some of
the most influential artists and
thinkers of the day the unknown woman of
the sen came to embody the era's concept
of beauty
some commenters have gone so far as to
claim that an entire generation of
german models and film stars styled
themselves on this anonymous drowned
girl's face
over time the death mask's popularity
began to wane
and if that's where this story ended
there's a good chance it would have been
entirely forgotten by now
but
about 65 years after the unknown woman's
death a twist of fate brought her back
to life again in spectacular fashion
during the 1950s a group of doctors
including austrian peter suffer were in
the process of laying the foundations
for cardiopulmonary resuscitation
better known by its catchier nickname
cpr
today cpr is one of the most widely
known and widely used emergency medical
procedures in the world but in the 50s
it was brand new with around three
quarters of all cardiac arrest taking
place outside of hospitals peter safra
recognized the potential for cpr to save
countless lives
and so he was keen to begin teaching
this technique to as many people as he
could
the problem was cpr is a tricky thing to
practice what they don't show you in the
movies is that cpr is a fairly brutal
procedure
try it out on a friend and you're liable
to break her ribs but safar had hit on a
novel idea to overcome this painful
little issue
he wanted to create a life-size doll to
be used in cpr training scenarios it
just so happens that safar was mates
with a toy maker by the name of asmond
leodoll who had all the know-how
necessary to bring the project to life
not only that but leodoll had saved his
two-year-old son from drowning some
years before and he knew the value of
first aid training
better than anyone leodoll figured that
he should make the doll female since
macho types in 1950s would have been
unwilling to lock lips with a doll of
their own gender the design was coming
along well except for one thing the doll
needed a face
and it was here that liodel remembered
that oddly enchanting cast of a young
woman that had hung for years in a
relative's house
as i'm sure you've guessed by now the
cast was of the unknown woman of the sen
by 1960 liadel's doll with the drowned
girl's face was on sale under the name
of rasusi anne it was the first patient
simulator ever made and over the next 60
years or so it would be used to train
literally hundreds of millions of people
in the use of cpr
which in turn has saved an estimated
2 million lives and counting
it's for this reason the unknown woman
of the sun has been called the most
kissed person in the world
i know that's kind of cheating but hey i
didn't make it up
resusci anne has been sold all over the
world but in the us she's typically
known as cpr annie
one of the steps taught to those
learning cpr is to check whether the
patient's responsive by asking her a
question when using the cpr annie doll
that question is usually annie are you
okay
no doubt that phrase sounds familiar
because it's one of the most famous
lyrics in all of pop music sung by
michael jackson on the 1988 single
smooth criminal
that isn't just a coincidence either i
don't know if you've ever listened to
the lyrics but smooth criminal is about
a woman being attacked and badly injured
in her apartment
the famous chorus is an allusion to cpr
annie and therefore the unknown woman of
the sen
whether or not the king of pop ever knew
he was singing about a drowned girl
who'd been dead for hundreds of years
i guess we'll never know
i should point out that some people have
questioned whether the unknown woman of
the sun really was found dead in the
river all those years ago
her face is remarkably well preserved
something that isn't often seen with
bodies that have spent a significant
amount of time in water though it isn't
unheard of
it's been suggested that she was instead
a model a deceased tuberculosis sufferer
or possibly the daughter of a german
mask maker though there's no compelling
evidence to support those claims either
whoever she was and however she died
one thing's for certain the unknown
woman of the sen has lived one hell of
an afterlife
thanks for watching